hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the phoenix candidates tournament
2022 it's hikaru nakamura versus
yanipaneshi yan uh leading the
tournament um uh in seoul lead and
nakamura uh
still on two points he did lose that
game to fabi in round one so a win with
the white pieces against nipple here
would definitely go a long way for him
as he would catch up to him and maybe
maybe even uh share first place at least
for a while so it's a it's a really fun
game you i'm sure you guys are going to
enjoy it let's check it out as it comes
from the petrol of defense and hikaru
opens with e4 we have e5 by on knight to
f3 and young goes for the petrol defense
knight to f6 we have knight captures on
e5 and the d6 so uh it's a very very uh
nice opening for both white and black
caruana used it against magnus carlsen
in the
in in the wheelchairs championship match
so there has been quite a lot of work
done uh on it uh knight back to f3 and
knight captures on e4 this is the
classical variation the absolute main
line d4 d5 and now bishop to d3 i'm sure
you guys had this position on on your
boards uh
more than once so here knight to c6 uh
and uh
uh he carved just castles with bishop to
e7c for now and going after the bishop
with the bishop to beef with knight to
b4 so again this is all been played many
many times bishop e2 we have castles and
knight to c3 bishop to f5 and now pawn
to a3 trying to chase away this knight
so we can pick up the d5 pawn so of
course black can just move the knight uh
first we have to trade knight captures
on c3
uh so we remove one of the attackers of
the d5 pawn b captures and only now we
move back the knight knight to c6 rook
to e1 by hikaru rook to e8 and now uh
this is already where the the fun starts
the most uh common move here is just c
captures on d5 after after which black
recaptures second most popular is just
bishop to f4 nicely continuing
development uh but hikaru plays rook to
a2 and it's a really really uh
uh funny move because well that's a
funny square for the rook but also uh
it's very useful as the bishop covers
this diagonal the b1 square is covered
by the bishop we can put the rook on b2
and claim the b file for ourselves and
uh as the bishop has already been
developed the b7 pawn is somewhat weak
and also if this bishop moves for
example bishop f1 or bishop to d3 or
even black captures we recapture which
is very unlikely we can shift this rook
over to the e2 square and the double
rooks and the e file so this is very
nicely done by hikaru uh yam plays
bishop to f8
an extremely rare move played in only
one game uh soyun
you know doesn't just mess around
and here we have c captures on d5 and
this is a new move by hikaru so already
as of move 15 we have a completely new
game uh interestingly a4 here was played
in the game alexinko versus lechevsky in
the russian cup final 2017 where
alexenko won a very nice game i was
playing in huntyman sisk
but like i said see captures on the e5 a
completely new game and this is
basically where our game truly begins so
here nepo captures with the queen
develops it and attacks the rook on a2
and hikaru could just move it for
example rook to b2 but he still wants to
wait with the rook he he just he doesn't
just want to play this nipple can always
just play b6 and uh it's not maybe the
greatest square for the rook so instead
first c4 chases away the queen from this
active square sorry not there that was a
there was a mouse slip uh and uh well it
seems like you just go back queen d6 or
queen d7 or queen to d8 depending on wha
what do you prefer unless you are
yanipanishing then you go forward uh
queen to e4 and this looks incredibly
weird just putting your queen in front
of the rook like this uh luckily hikaru
does not have any uh good discoveries
with the bishop so he just goes bishop
to f1 uh asks nipple what is your queen
doing on e4 that's i mean that's a
really weird square for the queen and
now nipple plays a queen to g4 brings
the queen over to the attack and this is
a bit too ambitious here the actual real
tricky way to play this with black would
be queen to b1 and it looks silly
because well you can just allow white
rook captures on e8 rook capture 78 and
now rook to b2 winning the b7 pawn
but that's exactly what you should do
queen a1 we're going to play rook
captures on b7 and now bishop to e4
and once uh we we give up one more pawn
then bishop comes here and this uh looks
like a position that nipple would very
much enjoy playing he's down two pawns
uh but he will win the eighth three pawn
so he's just gonna be down one point
he's going to have the past a pawn and
he's going to have uh well this counter
play with the bishop pair with the
active queen with the rook on the open e
file uh it would be very very
interesting to see at this position on
the board but he goes for queen to g4
and this is now just weird because
hikaru plays h3 and fairly quickly at
that and now what do you do with with
the queen the problem is if you play
something like queen to g6 we're gonna
play d5 chase away this knight uh and
after let's say a trade first rook
captures queen captures and knights to
e7 now we're gonna play g4 and now uh
okay we're not threatening this because
the g pawn is pinned but we are
threatening this double attack with
knight h5 and then we just pick up the
bishop so the bishop will have to go
back we're going to play rook to e2
claim the e file for ourselves and um
it's a much better position for white
nipple still has to develop all of his
pieces and it's not winning uh you know
outright winning but it would be very
very difficult to find moves for black
here but okay that's kind of what uh
what nipple usually does so i guess
maybe maybe he
would enjoy play playing this uh but
instead we have rook capture sunny one
first uh queen capture sunny one and now
queen to e4 this is how
ayan decides to play it uh rook to e2
and now
what do you do with the queen uh there
really aren't all that many good squares
uh for example let's uh just give uh
give this queen to b1 move a try uh if
you play this uh then d5 pretty much
wins the game that's the sad reality of
of black's uh pieces uh let's say knight
to a7 now comes rook to b2 queen has to
move light to queen to a4 we're going to
play rook captures on b7 you'll grab the
pawn this is now a weak pawn this is a
weak poem black has absolutely no
compensation here for example queen
captures on e1 we're gonna play knight
captures it's uh it's uh
uh just an unplayable position for black
there is
nothing for you to do here so instead uh
jan plays the only move available for
black in order not to lose the game on
the spot that is queen to d3 and now uh
can hikaru
move the rook somewhere are there any
good discoveries here
uh well it seems like you could play
something like rook to e5 uh just uh you
know try and force the queen away from
the defense of the bishop but there's
always this queen to b1 square you're
gonna be defending the bishop so that's
not the way to do it uh so here hikaru
actually tries uh rook to b2 uh but only
once now young goes back queen to e4 he
offers a queen trade and here you can't
really trade if you go for rook captures
on b7 now we're just gonna trade queens
captures captures and now knight
captures on d4 as the knight moved to
recapture the queen so the d4 square is
not covered and even if rook captures on
c7 we're gonna continue the game uh
bring the bishop in and it's gonna be uh
well white is up a pawn but nothing too
scary
uh so instead rook to e2 hikaru repeats
the position we queen to d3 and now
comes the moment uh where you know good
things could have happened uh hikaru
plays rook to e3 but just for fun uh you
can even pause the video yourselves and
try to find
a move that gives blank the most uh
problems so while i give you a couple of
seconds try and spot this idea uh have
at it
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
tricky idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is knight
to h4 now that's that seems to be the
trickiest move because now uh we are
already attacking the bishop and now if
black just leaves the queen on d3 now we
play knight rook to e5 and we we will be
attacking the bishop twice we're gonna
have an open attack on the queen and the
black will just resign so
you can't really play just anything here
uh you have to move the queen let's the
queen to b1 now we attack the knight to
d5 knight to d4 and now queen to b2
again it's gonna be a very very similar
position to what we've discussed uh
let's say queen to e4 we can trade here
captures captures and now rook captures
and b7 right it's just going to be a uh
incredibly difficult position to defend
for black with the weak seepaw and the
weak a pawn but okay hikaru played rook
to e3 and now young happily goes to b1
with the queen we have d5 it's similar
but not the same
because now knight to e7 and here
it looks like maybe you can just grab
the knight and give up the rook for for
uh knight and bishop the problem is your
bishop on c1 will be hanging if we do
that so you can't do that uh you could
play knight to d4 which is interesting
he car went knight to d2 he went after
nepal's queen but after knight to d4 uh
we attacked the bishop here so now we
are actually threatening rook capture
snipe bishop captures and uh
well okay not right away as the queen is
uh still guarding the bishop uh but it
is a a very hard position for black to
play but black would have this beautiful
queen to b6 move now just attacking the
knight uh and after queen to d2 now we
play bishop back to c8 so it's very
passive for black but it should be
it should be playable so that's uh why
he car decided on knight to d2 he this
is what he played attacked nipples queen
now we have queen to a1
uh and now we have knight to b3 again
attacking the queen
because this is still not an option the
bishop on c1 would be hanging so now
knight to b3 this defends the bishop and
now uh what can you play will of course
queen to f6 we have to defend our our
knight here bishop to d2 now preparing
bishop to see three to grab hold of this
diagonal and not knight the g6 this is
uh
you have to play this see if if uh
hikaru starts chasing away the queen
then the knight becomes the target and
that's going to be a problem so knight
to g6 and now we have knight to a5 again
bishop to c3 is possible but now the
queen can move to d8 and the okay the
the game just continues but um
white should always be better however
here knight to a5 was played going after
the b7 pawn but now nipple just defends
at b6 with knight to c6 and the bishop
back to d7 slowly but surely nipple
improving his position by quite a lot
bishop the c3 now finally grabbing hold
of this diagonal
and now queen to d6 and nepal played
this move pretty much instantly uh even
though a lot of people were saying
magnus crossing including uh included
that queen to g5 was maybe the way to go
now you are putting a lot of pressure on
um on white's position uh but the
question is after rook the g3 chasing
away the queen queen h5 the rook can go
back still keep an eye on the e file uh
what do you play here uh black can just
always play uh this bishop captures pawn
captures and it does look uh like
something you've doubled the the c pawns
maybe this pawn is weak uh however uh uh
objectively not not a lot uh to be done
here so nepo decided to play queen to d6
instead and now hikaru plays bishop to
b4 he attacks the queen and uh well uh
i'm sure you guys know where this is
going
another good try would be g3 just
continue the game play play a move give
up the a3 pawn and if black captures it
and of course ian would capture this as
it is the strongest move we're gonna
play h4 try and uh kick away the knight
and after h5 we can even play bishop
captures on g7 open up a discovery on
the queen uh there would be this
incredible rook to e8 move now if you
capture the queen we capture the queen
on e1 and here we would have this uh
very nice bishop captures king captures
through captures with czech bishop
captures with check and the game
continues uh with white uh
being always a little better due to
black having uh such an exposed king but
probably not nothing serious
uh it is one way to keep the game going
though uh however in the game bishop to
b4 was played queen to f6 by on and now
bishop to c3 we have queen to d6 uh and
now bishop to b4 queen to f6 bishop to
c3 and he was in this position that the
arbiter got in the middle of them and
said uh guys this is a draw by threefold
repetition and of course it is now a
draw so instead of repeating maybe
nipple could have after let's say bishop
to c3 went qui queen to g5 again uh
something that magnus mentioned that he
he should have maybe gone for for
for some blood uh but uh he he obviously
was happy with the draw here as he did
have a shaky position he got out of it
and well he is the leader of the
tournament he doesn't wanna
maybe risk too much and uh even lose the
game so it would be a nice attempt but
nothing serious the the knight can go
back we're gonna play bishop to c5 there
are nice moves for for both white and
black here for example knight to f3
attack the queen queen goes back now we
offer a trade of bishops so nothing
serious uh it's just a matter of whether
you want to continue or not uh the
problem is uh for hikaru hikaru had six
minutes on the clock so he didn't really
have all that much to think about he he
just wanted to repeat uh he still needs
to make six more moves to reach time
control which can be can be problematic
nipple had almost 50 minutes on the
clock so for an input wouldn't really be
a problem uh but you've seen how easy it
would be if he goes for queen g5 to make
those a couple of moves um not uh not
all that much uh uh
to to think about
uh so yeah
that's the first game we're covering
from round five really uh a nice uh nice
um uh try by hikaru uh but when when he
at that one moment where he should have
spent a little bit more time and maybe
maybe went for this knight to h4 uh move
uh it's uh it's not maybe uh
for a fourth winning line uh but uh you
know
like we said after queen to b1 you will
win this b7 pawn and it's just going to
be impossible to
rook to b2 queen to e4 we're gonna trade
captures captures now rook captures on
b7 it's in uh
in in a practical game this would be
incredibly difficult for ian to hold so
uh hikar will
very likely do a video of his own where
he will explain his thought process but
until that happens we are you know
in in the dark regarding that but uh
probably it had something to do with
uh with um
being uh low on time but maybe maybe
they are both just so good that they
know that white will not be able to push
this for a win uh but you know uh it
does seem like a decent try uh so once
again uh that's the first game we're
showing from round five hope you guys
enjoyed that another uh well uh clean
performance by nipple who just uh seems
to play effortlessly even though
sometimes he gets in a little bit of
trouble uh he doesn't really uh catch up
to him like he was against fabiana
caruana but fabio was down also 10
minutes or maybe even below 10 minutes
on the clock and he couldn't pursue that
uh uh positional uh sacrifice with uh
giving up the rook for the bishop and
you know they just agreed to draw by
threefold repetition so going extremely
well for nipple we'll see how it goes
we're gonna probably cover some other
games from round five as well
so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed it i would like to thank casey
vance uh paul uh julian harmley and uh
banerjee for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
to my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day